and we want it to be beautiful and lush
and romantic
just like a nancy meyers movie she's our
favorite director oh
i love you've got mail that's nora
ephron you idiot i know
hey i saw you earlier you weren't in the
bathroom you were on a park bench
playing on your phone
yeah you left me to do everything while
i thought you were pooping
i wish you were pooping i wish to god
i'm sorry oh
rosa crying don't know what to do
pat pat this feels wrong we put away
figgis three weeks ago
pimento should have been back by now we
had plans to meet on that park bench
once the coast was clear
he hasn't shown up maybe he's deep
undercover or
he doesn't remember who he is or maybe
he's dead wow
thanks you're right my fiance is a total
weirdo who's probably dead
i'll just give up on him and go do my
paperwork no
diaz wait maybe he's just really really
injured
come on amy i've only had arlo for a day
and a half
but if anything happened to him i would
kill everyone in this room and then
myself
very violent eulogy i like it charles
i'm sorry
you don't have to get over it take as
long as you want i want to apologize for
yesterday
inserting myself into my employee's
breakup with my nephew somehow
uh backfired that's nerdfall i'm the one
that made us seem like a dumb crying
baby
i'm considering having my tear ducts
melted shut it's not the end of the
world to feel
things i guess not it's up there
the thing is i really cared about marcus
but he wanted to get married and
i'm just not ready for that and if i'm
not ready with a guy as great as marcus
then what if i'm never ready
what if that was it my one chance of
love
and what if i never get a second chance
i don't know
i'm just i'm just sad
well i i understand
it must be very difficult
wait are you crying yes
thank you for acknowledging my feelings
thank you for acknowledging mine
we're both great at this i'm going to
the dumb party but only because i don't
want to hurt marcus i'm still
super mad at you um like how you stole
super mad at gilmore girls for how the
finale went down
i just want to see laura lie happy no
i can't do it what i thought you wanted
us to change you i thought i did too
but i don't i like having emotions okay
this is who i am you're leaving and
that's a really big change and i'm gonna
cry about it a lot
okay and there it is another flawless
gina moment
what what's going on amy the lesson i
wanted to leave you with is to just
be yourself if you want to cry like an
idiot for hours on end just
do it you want to make a big old ugly
book full of all my brilliant thoughts
do it do you
it's gina
oh wow that was really really sweet
oh dip i got rosa to feel her feelings
too
inadvertent gina moment two for one
come in my babies come in what are you
doing here
i wanted to say i'm sorry i reacted
poorly last night
this is all new to me i know but it's
also not new
you know i'm still the same person i
always was but i don't feel i know that
person
dad my fault not yours i want you to be
able to tell me
everything i can't promise you all
understand
but i'm trying i want you to know that i
accept you for who you
are and i love you very very much
i love you too
so dance i figured out why you want to
win i hacked your work calendar those
calendars are public everyone on the
system has access
i acted i'm a hacker anyhow you took a
vacation 14 days ago and yet you already
want another day off odd unless you
need it for a unique once-in-a-lifetime
occurrence
perhaps a proposal to your girlfriend
jocelyn
what you've been dating for a year you
met each other's parents and you just
got your nails done
to present her with a ring
jocelyn broke up with me what i want the
day off so i can sit alone listen to
death metal and get my head right
but what about my nail polish solve
getting my nails done made me feel
better for a second
ah this is a trick to throw me off i bet
things are better than ever
and you oh you really are crying
welcome to my most sadistic creation the
tangled nightmare of extension cords
that lives
in our supply closet your mission is to
untangle
your lamp's cord plug it in and then
pull yourself to it on your dolly and
turn it on ah nice
hitchcock's coming down from the speed i
have a chance
freaks begin
[Music]
what is that grab the top one and yank
the bottom one oh my god that's what you
meant
although i'm open to whatever you want
to try here we go diaz i want to
apologize
i'm not talking to you oh oh
it worked the pegging worked what no
here we go
gotcha you're never gonna catch me oh
yeah
yeah yes i did it and hitchhike's gonna
lose
rosa and holter gonna beat him rosa stop
i give up
i want you to know i'm sorry for prying
win this thing and enjoy your day off
and if you ever want a friend to sit
with you and silently listen to death
metal
just know i'm always here
okay i'd like that yes you should be
very proud of yourself
i know things aren't exactly where you
want to be right now but uh
i promise you they will improve thank
you captain every time someone steps up
and says who they are
the world becomes a better more
interesting place
so thank you
five six seven eight eyes up
shoulders down well that wasn't terrible
see serge tough love works oh here he
comes
oh man bolt cutters bolt cutters have
literally never been used by an innocent
person
i use them all the time when i make
jewelry what oh my god follow-up
questions later i shouldn't grab so much
but my brunch
say it's the only way to promote my
handmade jewelry line brunch what
homemade
what else focus all right gina we have
to act soon
that cold medicine diaz chugged it was
the non-drowsy kind
she's all over the place hey hey hey hey
guess what yeah i got a new lead to ask
my perv about this drug dealer on state
street whoa why doesn't someone answer
that phone
get it i would get it hello i know
there's no michael here give the wrong
number goodbye
okay i'm michael that's a dumb name but
it's yours and you should be proud of it
because you are the greatest detective
i've ever known
no doy do you have no door where is
my file yeah she's so hopped up on that
stuff her brain's gonna blow
i'm gonna interrogate the perp you keep
diaz occupied
i don't want to get near her germ face
permission to lock her in a distant room
no just distract her yes that is what i
will do
rosa come here got to tell you something
it's a secret
okay but i have a lot of stuff to do
secretly
everything okay with diaz yeah she fell
asleep five minutes after i locked her
in and she hasn't moved in the past 10
hours
she talks in her sleep i'm gonna rip
your head off
i'm gonna rip your damn head off grandma
oh terra bear what if she sleeps forever
[Music]
oh look rosa you look great girl
i gotta get out of here bye better not
run because i will catch you after i'm
done crushing that perp you are next
i already interrogated the perp for you
you what i got him to name his giggle
pig supplier it's all good now go home
and get better
i could have done it myself no you
couldn't have you literally have been in
a coma since yesterday
now i know you like to act like you
don't need any help but we all do
look i asked five dudes to spot me when
i'm doing my squats
terry paid me 20 to lock you up no
i did not but i took that cheddar and i
made you this special
rosa's gonna make this called her [ __ ]
care package
now's the time when you say thank you
for all your help
thank you for all your help
wait is that a smile i see possibly
my immune system is too weak to fight
off my smile muscles
um i just wanted to thank you for all
your help yesterday i didn't do much
it was nothing good day what's going on
just very busy get back to work
wait what do you have in there
a balloon arch oh my god captain she is
magnificent
vindication
you